c'est un peu l'opération de la dernière
chance une soixantaine de familles du
quartier pointe des à fort de
france font face à une situation inédite
ils payent des impôts fonciers alors
qu'ils ne sont pas propriétaires de leur
logement situé sur la zone des 50 pas
géométriques les dettes fiscales
s'accumulent comme pour la mère de
vanity ils ont pris tous les souks elles
avaient toutes les économies de toute sa
vie
ce tous ses comptes donc elle a été
assez choqué
moi je me suis emparé de la ferme se
monter aux impôts bonne foi et en plus
ce qu'ils aient pris tous les sous il
lui reste encore beaucoup beaucoup à
payer des habitants pris à la gorge avec
des saisies administrative sur compte
des lettres d'huissier des mises en
demeure de payer d'un côté
l'administration fiscale les considère
comme propriétaire de l'autre les
services de l'état ne leur délivre pas
de titre de propriété
leurs avocats ont déposé un recours nous
sommes venus pour dire en fait aux
services et aux responsables des
services des impôts que là vous
commettez en fait une égalité et cette
illégalité en fait à des conséquences
extrêmement fait sur la vidéo et des
autres et qu'il faut que ça cesse il
faut que ça cesse immédiatement
raphaël thones vie sur ce terrain
familial depuis des années un conflit
oppose avec la d aller la préfecture sa
mère s'est installée sur ce lopin de
terre en 1968
depuis le terrain situé sur les
cinquante pas géométriques a été classé
zone naturelle par un arrêté préfectoral
datant de 2005 empêchant ainsi toute
régularisation sont déléguées habitue
donc ce sont des lois écrites par
certaines personnes qui ne les
appliquent pas si certaine logique ils
transgressent eux mêmes les lois qu'il
clique qui kills qu'il rédige des
familles qui vivent ici depuis une
cinquantaine d'années comme le père de
christian qui a 110 ans est le doyen des
français
son père père soit 800 euros de retraite
et il devait plus de 8000 euros de taxe
foncière la moitié a déjà été saisie sur
ses comptes ses enfants sont pourtant
prêts à payer
déjà ici
le droit de racheter qu'on achète qu'on
paye nos impôts à partir des trv
obligataires et qu'en fait tout le monde
a peur parce qu'on ne voit pas qu'est-ce
qui ça d'eux et ça ça devait être comme
ça les habitants de la pointe des
mène de nombreux combats celui
d'aujourd'hui était fiscale et celui
d'hier continuera encore demain pour
l'obtention d'un titre de propriété